welcome to this video playing FM amnesia
from Greece at least a grease like maybe
the Kings Indian for a change usually
under entertaining entertaining games
they often feel a little bit lost them
admittedly yeah when I was still playing
the Kings in you regularly i went for
the night a six variation there then you
fire fan hmm i really have forgotten how
how i went about that i think with this
and then 98 but it's been a long time
sure what seems to be a bit better here
fire look at this now with my let's say
with my somewhat more experience to you
I played that when I was in my 20s maybe
you are more optimistic even than today
that looks a bit strange down with a
night on a six but this is how you can
play this opening I believe rook c8 yeah
I'm a bit worried about the a7 ponder
maybe this is very maybe that's it's
it's completely irrelevant the pawn
hmm Scott nights you for coming I would
like to play rook c8 really badly okay
maybe I can maybe I should get this
night night back into the game we're
thinking nie da da das got Bishop c5
anyway do I have roots II ate some kind
of trick here I don't have I don't have
that okay I have to go here as weird as
it looks but I can go b6 nexim fights
it's not it's not losing or anything
this pin I hope doesn't look very nice
but I think be six horse most of the
most of the coordination issues
okay yeah I don't have much choice that
I have to play that okay now probably
probably whoopsie eight first mmm ya
gots lots of things traded yeah b6 he
will take it here c6 there that sets bit
of a bit of a problem takes takes takes
like to activate this bishop maybe I can
put it on g5 there
yeah every 100 I never thought about
that one oh Jesus getting f7 thats it's
very very simple okay is there any way
to deviate
not really I don't have chicks or
something no check I have one threat
here queen bee success if you are if you
have to resort to one movers you know
you're in trouble the only hope there is
that some endgame see are not directly
lost like opposite colored bishops are
not directly loss
Jeff start with the chick and maybe him
yeah like him
oh I totally overlooked that that's that
little little tactic that he had okay so
he threatening made
Jim
just just looking for some way to to fry
it a little bit at least not that so
it's very it's very nice morning it's
very lost really maybe a check the a3
pawn them I think something like Bishop
d7 just might be a some kind of mating
attack Bishop g76
57 looks pretty like like pretty strong
with them yeah can I take them probably
not
there's no way to continue even
Jim the one movers are not working hey
okay yeah just I just slack I recently
landed into this simple move them yeah
it didn't didn't look too great but this
this cannot be the big reputation of my
setup and thinking I it should be
essentially okay though don't think I'm
in a huge problem I got huge problems
here I just shouldn't blunder into
something very simple here yeah this
just loses maybe h5 Bishop h6 the
computer gives why the clear advantage
I'm not quite sure why I understand the
two bishops but I mean I'm not even much
worse if i play b6 them I don't believe
it something it's just so bad i don't i
don't see why this is so bad I'm again
blundering f7 else I'm always blundering
of 70 okay so maybe this is not a good
idea but what if I just give up on this
on this bloody idea and just stay for b6
this is so bad I mean I don't like the
position very much that that much is
clear but I don't is this so terrible
computer even gives this s good for what
don't see that really i mean the pad the
protected passer is really nothing in
this position really not much okie it
wants to take into this
ok it's not equal equal it's not yet
what is a bit better than but it's not
sure about the big edge that the comp is
giving like one pawn something that I
really don't believe yeah it's not a
very nice position I think this is the
line I mean I studied it back then but I
have forgotten how it is played down and
maybe I have to be more concrete there
with checkers or something this may be
an idea that's what the computer gives
that's funny yeah maybe you have to play
something something like that something
a little bit more more active there but
way I have free forgotten how this is
this is played ok thanks for watching